Vous avez l'impression que cette pipe est énorme, n'est-ce pas ?
Eh bien non, tout n'est question que de perspective !
Vous souvenez-vous de ce fameux jeu auquel on avait joué
qui jouait sur les perspectives ?
Ça fait beaucoup de "jouer" dans une seule phrase.
Et j'parle pas de celui là .*couinement*
Bah, je mettrais le lien dans la description pour ceux qui l'ont pas vu,
mais tu pouvais dedans prendre un objet, et le faire devenir énorme en l'éloignant.
Voilà, par exemple prendre la Tour Eiffel et la faire devenir, euh, un porte-clés, Tour Eiffel
Et bah j'ai trouvé un deuxième jeu du même genre
qui a l'air, c'est un peu différent mais vous allez voir c'est tout aussi cool.
C'est un jeu où le fond est noir,
les objets sont tous en blanc mais ils n'ont pas de contours ni d'ombre.
Ce qui fait que tu as beaucoup de mal à différencier les objets
et que le seul moyen de les différencier c'est de tourner autour pour que la perspective change.
Vous avez compris, faites pas genre, vous avez comp... Eh franchement j'me suis craqué pour que mes explications soient compréhensibles !
C'est parti, y'a 16 niveaux, et mec on va s'craquer le cerveau une fois de plus mais c'est trop cool.
Allez c'est parti !
Donc on apparaît devant cette forme et en avançant et en tournant
on va se rendre compte que voilà !
Qu'en fait, il y avait 2 formes.
Tout simplement. J'espère que vous trouvez ça génial aussi.
Du coup, on va devoir monter là-desus et le but de chaque level,
c'est d'aller prendre la petite boule [NB : boule qui est en fait un cube...] jaune qui se situe, ici.
Voilà.
Alors, level suivant.
Hop !
Bon là, c't'assez simple. Ah nan
putain, du coup le pont est blanc sur blanc.
Alors attends, comment on peut voir ça ?
Faudrait qu'j'arrive à m'baisser,
nan, regardez, je vois grâce au noir là.
Ah merde.
Ok donc il fait cette forme. Putain, c'est mali-in !
C'est super malin.
Du coup à mon avis.
Là.
...
Ouais putain c'est...
Ah merde ! Tin, c'est dur !
Il y a une technique particulière vous pensez ? Pour
bien apercevoir le truc quand on est dessus ou pas ?
J'crois pas.
Là.
Et là maintenant, c'est un peu droit genre.
...
Ouais, ouais. Nan !
Nan, nan !
...
Quoi ?
Y'a un trou !
Nan mais mec,
mais c'est super dur de ouf !
C'est hyper chaud.
Grâce à ce trait noir, j'vois à peu près où est le trou.
Vous voyez ?
...
Ah nan, mais même pas mec.
J'suis aller au culot !
Voilà, yolo !
C'est très malin en vrai comme jeu.
Putain, on a fait 3 levels, mon gars, j'me sens plus.
...
Mais là on ne comprend rien !
On comprend rien, sa mère !
Je saute au cas où, j'pense qu'il faut sauter à mort.
...
Faut plus sauter qu'Mario.
Et là, du coup, j'fais comment pour voir c'qu'il y a ?
À mon avis, y doit y avoir une passerelle, un truc caché, c'est sûr.
...
Nan faut que je saute comme ça tout droit ?
Oui !
...
Non !
Donc ok y'a rien de compliqué en fait, c'est juste une montée
et derrière y'a un grand saut à faire,
mais c'est dur de voir où atterrir parce que
y'a du blanc, qui est le principe même du jeu !
Donc y'a bien un trou, ok j'ai compris la forme.
En fait, faut monter,
là, en vrai ça va à gauche ici.
Hop !
...
Et voilà, c'est faux.
Ne m'écoutez jamais.
Attends, on va tourner autour car c'est ce qu'on a pas assez fait, je trouve.
Ah ok ! J'ai compris !
Ça en fait, c'est juste une paroi !
C'est pas un support.
Ça, c'est juste une paroi.
Et moi j'ai l'impression que c'était un pont !
Si votre cerveau explose, c'est normal, vous en faites pas.
Là, en fait, j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un pont.
Et en fait c'est faux il y a juste une paroi à la verticale
et un truc plat.
Donc, il faut que je saute de l'autre côté !
comme j'avais fait t'à l'heure
Et là normalement.
...
On est dessus.
Wouh, tin c'était compliqué mon gars c'lui là.
...
C'est quoi le piège là ? Je ne comprends pas le piège.
Haaan.
...
Oh les putes !
Et j'fais comment là ?
...
J'croyais qu'c'était des dalles noires
et blanches mais nan !
Y'a que des dalles noires et des dalles transparentes !
Mais vu qu'en dessous c'est du blanc, j'ai l'impression que c'est... oh putain.
C'est horrible parce que notre cerveau associe le blanc du coup, à un truc sur lequel on peut marcher,
et le noir à du vide.
Et vu qu'un coup sur deux, il y a vraiment,
bref, c'est juste la profondeur de champ, c'est terrible !
Oui donc là, il faut que je marche que sur les noires.
C'est ça la technique.
Nan en vrai hein.
Donc on va faire une diagonale.
Y'aura pas une dalle noire où d'un coup elle se transforme...
Comme ç...
Mais nan !
Oh les bâtards !
J'ai compris le truc du niveau, c'est hyper malin !
En gros à droite,
les dalles sur lesquelles je peux marcher, c'est les noires.
Le reste, c'est des dalles transparentes sur un fond blanc en bas,
donc j'ai l'impression que voilà.
Et à gauche, c'est l'inverse !
C'est les dalles blanches sur lesquelles j'peux marcher,
et les dalles noires qui sont en faites transparentes.
Voilà, c'est le sol qu'est noir.
C'est trop malin mec, c'est trop fort, j'adore.
Y'a des gens qui aiment le sudoku,
d'autres les mots croisés,
d'autres les jeux qui tuent ton cerveau.
Le problème c'est que.. A quel moment j'peux voir la..
Ah regardez, là on voit
Là, hop.
Et voilà. Maintenant on passe sur le blanc. Et le noir c'est le sol qu'il y a en bas.
J'explique au cas où. Si ça trouve vous avez pas besoin d'explications de.. boloss.
Mais..
On est dessus ! Yes !
Donc j'pense qu'il faut vraiment tourner autour pour voir.
Par exemple là, vous voyez, on dirait qu'il y a juste un truc blanc. Mais en fait, c'est faux !
Y'a truc noir devant l'truc blanc.
Oh y'a une pa.. Oh les passerelles ça va être dur de les voir..
* inspire *
Tu vois la passerelle blanche que quand elle est sur fond noir et tu vois la passerelle noire que quand elle est sur fond blanc..
Putain, j'aime trop.
J'ai trouvé le jeu qui tue le plus ton cerveau de tous les jeux qu'on à pu faire !
Donc là, elle est là, à peu près, j'la vois
Ok j'bou...
Ah merde ! Faut que j'me déplace en même temps en plus !?
C'est pas : j'suis dessus et elle m'emmène. C'est que j'dois avancer en même temps !
Ah la la la la..
Donc le mieux à mon avis, c'est d'prendre la noire..
J'ai l'habitude des jeux vidéos x2
Ca l'fait
Yes!
Alors ici on a ... wow qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel ?
Ok ...
Ah! On est de profil sur fond blanc
Là on est bien
Là on se rend compte !
Et encore je suis sûr y'a des trucs blancs qu'on voit pas
Comme ça on s'en rendrait compte?
Nan c'est bon il y a vraiment que du noir
Y'a que du noir mais je vais devoir faire tout ça de face
Donc regardez moi ça
Hop et là ...
Je n'vois plus rien ! Je peux plus évaluer les distances c'est fini pour moi
Donc je crois que ... peut-être de côté je peux la voir apparaître
Nan ?
J'crois y'en avait une là ouais on la voit à peu près grâce au fond blanc
Putain mais mec c'est tellement bien joué
BRAVO !
*clap clap clap*
Allez la pipe donne nous du courage
Faut que je la nettoie parce qu'à mon avis y'a genre 18 maladies dessus
Vu toutes les fois où je l'ai fait tomber par terre
Il se passe quoi là ?
Ça c'est un mur ...
Ça c'est un mur
*découverte ouf* HAN Là
Là y'a un trou
À droite c'est  un mur, là c'est un mur
Donc faut contourner comme ça
Oh putain ok d'accord
Ah ok j'étais dans un cube ! Ok...
Putain mais mec !
C'est ce que ce jeu me met dans la gueule à chaque seconde !
Alors est-ce que je peux sauter là ?
Yeahhhh
Ah du coup je vois pas le trou ! Parce que le trou c'est que du noir ...
Mais il est là !
Je le sais je l'ai vu
Et merde ...
Il est un peu plus sur la gauche ... Vraiment en face
Quand je suis là faut que je saute tout droit
Donc logiquement , on va là et là non c'est tout droit en fait
Voilà !
Voilà voilà voilà
Vous vous êtes rendus compte ? Vous êtes contents ? Moi oui !
Nouveau niveau
Où sommes-nous ?
Que du blanc !
Et un seul mur noir
On va tourner autour ... Le truc jaune est là [le truc qui est un cube]
Il est , du coup , sur une mini plateforme qui est derrière cette plateforme là
C'est comme tout à l'heure ça va être dur de s'ren...
Mais ... comment je fais pour monter ?
Y'a rien pour monter ...
Une paroi noir , un bloc, un bloc, un autre bloc là
Et ça c'est un cube escalier c'est ça ?
Comment je fais pour me rendre compte ? Faut que j'y aille au culot
Y'a un truc que je dois mal faire .. Chui où là ?
What the fuck ?
Nan mais là c'est chaud !
D'accord c'est une sorte d'escalier
C'est un escalier ... Et voilà on recommence ! REBELOTE !
À droite ... ?
y'a la marche, à gauche ...
Et là hop on est au plus haut
On sait qu'il y a une paroi tout droit
Et qu'il y a le cube jaune qu'est juste là [ENFIN, LE CUBE JAUNE !]
Ok c'est bon
Est-ce que vous avez compris quelque chose ? Oui ?
Génial !
Par contre là ça commence à
faire mal au crâne
Cette vidéo devrait être sponsorisée par  ... euh .. l'aspirine
Ce niveau il est pété par contre !
On voit tout !
Ah non quoique là on voit pas la dernière plateforme
*sss* EH BAH NON PAS BESOIN !
OhhhhhOhhhh ... oulà attends qu'est ce qu'il se passe là ?
On a juste un truc noir ...
avec un truc ...
Ça c'est du vide ... Tu paries que ça c'est du vide ?
On prend le pari !
Je fait gagner cet emballage vide si ce n'est pas du vide
ET BIM !
Allez vous me devez tous un emballage vide
J'vais toquer chez Intermarché je vais leur revendre au kilo
On va dev'nir riche
Par contre comment je fais pour monter ?
J'ai gagné un pari j'suis content mais comment j'remonte ?
Y'a des marches que je vois pas mec ...
C'est ça ?
Ah what ?
il faut sauter quoi
ok bref j'lai pris
Alors là
y'a du rouge maintenant ! Maintenant c'est du rouge ! Et du noir
Mais ça change pas le problème
Mais mec le parcours !
Là on commence à entrer dans les level avec une difficulté un peu ... saignante
comme ton steak le midi
Alors, le truc jaune est là-bas [le 'truc' de retour]
Y'a une petite passerelle qui va nous amener sur cette grosse passerelle
De cette  grosse pastrelle on va devoir ... Passerelle ! Et pas sauterelle
On va devoir sauter sur cette plus grande passerelle
Qui va nous amener là-dessus
Là-dessus on longe ça nous amène là
Et d'ici à mon avis il faut sauter là
D'ici va falloir sauter là-bas
Mais vu que c'est sur fond rouge je pourrais mieux voir le vide
Vous avez rien compris c'est pas grave
Ok vamos !
Ok . On saute !
On a rejoint la plateforme la plus grande
On saute on prend un racourcci
Comme c'est sur fond rouge je peux évaluer les distances
ce qui m'arrange énormément
Là je crois y'a un pont
voilà il suffit de sauter pour le voir apparaître
Et là par contre ... ok y'a un ptit carré juste là
Et là c'est full fond noir donc j'suis baisé
donc j'propose de SAUTER LÀ DSSUS !
YES !
WOUW ! Vous avez vu comment ça d'vient dur ?
C'est ça que j'adore la difficuté elle fait vraiment
c'est ... c'était une courbe
Ohhhhh
On pourrait croire à la pochette du prochain album de Justice
vrai ou faux ?
faux!
J'suis ça c'est beaucoup
plus profond qu'il n'y paraît... voilà j'en étais sûr !
rien de sexuel hein
Mais là ça va être chaud de différencier les différents reliefs
Hop ! Donc là ya un truc
ok c'est bon
Mais là mec j'peux rien différencier ... Si en me repérant par rapport au sol
C'est passé !
J'regarde par terre
Est-ce qu'à un moment il va me faire le coup de mettre du sol noir en dessous ?
Et du coup je vais croire que je continue à marcher là où il faut alors que non ?
Non c'est bon !
Putaiiiiiiiin mais mec c'est une arène le truc
On a une plateforme ici ...
qui va mener vers l'une de ces deux plateformes
Ah faut que je saute aussi ?
Là on voit bien ! Là on a une bonne perspective !
On a une bonne vue d'ensemble tvoi cke jveux dire
Est-ce que ? Ouais ça le fait
ouais ça le fait
ouais ça l'fait
Ah c'est une plateforme rouge
Excellent !
On dirait que le noir est divisé en deux mais nan !
Et là je peux y'aller ou va y'avoir du vide ?
Ça peut pas être aussi simple
Si c'est bon ? Ils ont pas fait leur pute jusqu'au bout ?
Oh mon dieu des gens gentils sur cette planète !
ah c'est bon
C'est la fin ?
J'suis sûr c'est une fake porte
Si c'est une fake porte je fais gagner ce ... x)
On parie combien ? c'est hyper profond
C'est vraiment une porte !
Mais nan ...
Oh mon dieu !
j'ai rien compris
J'ai rien compris mais c'était grave cool
Bah du coup je vous rends à tous vos déchets en plastique
Finalement je vais pas toquer chez intermarché *rire*
J'vous laisse devenir riche à ma place
Putain mec j'ai l'impression de revivre
de différencier les objets,
de voir un premier plan, un second plan, un troisième plan
règle de la photographie, on sait bien
on connait bien les cours d'arts plastiques au collège qui nous ont appris ça
C'est bon je l'ai vu c'est bon
pas obligé de m'aveugler
C'EST BON LE SOLEIL
Et c'est la fin ?
PUTAIN GÉNIAL !
Hééé ... j'me suis arrêté très très proche du mur
Quelle belle conclusion de merde pour un si beau jeu
Et voila les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur Contrast n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plu
J'ai adoré ce jeu !
J'adore les jeux comme ça !
Ça été fait en 24 heures et j'trouve qu'ils ont quand même eu le temps de développer 2-3 épreuves différentes
par exemple le truc des dalles où tout d'un coup elles s'inversent
Je suis boucheuh bée
N'hésitez pas dans les commentaires à m'dire si vous aimez bien les jeux comme ça qui jouent sur les perspectives
ou qui font bien réfléchir hein
... qui te crament ton cerveau finalement
À très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo, portez vous bien, tchao tout le monde
...
petit concours pour gagner..
*outro*